à l'occasion de la sortie du film une
intime conviction chicza reçoit marina
foïs pour un entretien exceptionnel sans
détour et sans tabou l'actrice répond
aux questions de jérôme becker bonjour
marina foïs bienvenue dans petit chat
avec nous vous aurez seul face à un
écran nos caméras et surtout vos images
celles de votre vie une vie de cinéma
mais pas que prête au vous trouvez
comment ce dispositif
salah oui tous à l'écran la chaise la
chaise je déteste parce que je suis
petit donc forcément le truc au pied
s'est jamais à ma taille je sais pas
comment m'asseoir je sais pas comment
tenir
je déteste par contre le sol laquelle m
bon eh bien c'est parti aujourd'hui vous
êtes venu nous parler d'une intime
conviction un film d'antoine rimbaud un
film sur la sphère suzanne viguier une
affaire qui depuis 2000 et après deux
procès reste à ce jour non élucidée
il vous parle d'une erreur judiciaire à
monsieur viguier vous avez mis trois
jours à déclarer la disparition de
l'autre phare en vrai ça peut même pas
s'il est mort d'un si ça se trouve elle
est partie il ya pas de calavi a pas de
mobile
dans ce film vous incarnez une femme
pleine de conviction et désireuse de
justice vous jouer aux côtés d'olivier
gourmet qui lui incarne l'avocat eric
dupond-moretti thé de sucre par an qu'on
parle pas français
après les saillies à souder d'or si je
prends mes repères je commence par bien
reçu mais c'est mieux que le sujet tout
des particules du premier procès ce rôle
vous l'avez accepté tout de suite
pourquoi oui bah parce qu'en fait
d'abord j'adore les films de procès
douze hommes en colère la vérité de
clouzot de sas et c'est des films que
j'adore et puis j'ai toujours eu une
attraction on peut un peu dégueulasse
pour le fait divers est un intérêt réel
pour la justice donc là c'était
l'occasion de de pouvoir relier un
fantasme de cinéma et un truc
de la vie réelle un sujet qui me
m'intéresse qui me touche
quelles sont les choses que vous
partagez n'aura votre personnage et vous
je suis un peu obsessionnel gêné j'ai
des comme ça c'est par période des
obsessions sur la tuna couche peut
décider d mais l'avocat il mangeait
beaucoup d'avocats mais tout le temps
quoi bon c'est pas un exemple très
intéressant mais je peux être habité par
un sujet ou un truc et puis je change
d'objets mais j'ai l'obsession je peux
comprendre je peux connaître
il y à peu vous étiez aussi au théâtre
sur la scène de l'odéon dans la pièce
les idoles de christophe honoré vous
incarnez lhomme le journaliste
l'écrivain le photographe aussi hervé
guibert disparu dans les années 90 il
était atteint du sida
[Musique]
alors je suis c'est un rat quelque chose
en quoi elle est importante pour vous
cette pièce pour plein de raisons
d'abord parce que c'est intéressant
quand même de se poser avec les années
qui nous donne ce recul là sur cette
période quand même une génération
d'artistes a été fauché il ya un gros
trou culturel tous ces artistes là dans
les années 90 tombaient comme des
mouches moi c'est mon époque c'est
l'époque de christophe honoré on avait
20 ans dans les années 90 et on à moi
j'ai enterré plein
d'amis très jeune et puis c'est honorer
j'adore ce qu'il fait depuis toujours
même avant de travailler avec lui j'ai
vu tous ses films j'ai lu ses livres je
trouve tout sexy chez nous on vous a vu
dans 23 pièces 48 long métrage mais
aussi cette cour et trois téléfilms
vous êtes né sous le signe du théâtre
enfin votre grand mère maternelle vous
emmenait régulièrement la comédie
française et votre baby sitter n'était
autre que le futur metteur en scène jean
marc brisset voilà alors que tout le
monde partout se met à danser sur un fil
[Musique]
vous prenez vos premiers cours de
théâtre vous n'avait que 7 ans quelques
années plus tard vous intégrez le cours
florent
mais pas le conservatoire disons que
j'ai raté le conservatoire aller
pourquoi toutes mes copines rentrait
donc j'étais très humilié j'ai pleuré
pendant un an faut dire que c'est
horrible je suis restée toute seule sur
le trottoir sarr que c'est vraiment
comme si on vous ferme la porte d'une
boîte de nuit qui va durer trois ans
quoi horrible mais au fond j'étais à 20
ans j'ai eu une période où je
réussissais tout et je pense que j'étais
arrivé à une période de melon assez
indescriptible et
ça m'a remis dans mes baskets c'était un
fantasme mais au fond je crois je suis
pas sûr que sa mort ait correspondu je
sais pas si j'ai bien quoi conjuguer le
verbe correspondre suscite ici c'est
parfait
alors maintenant on va regarder
quelqu'un que vous aimez bien
[Musique]
alors si tu es in china était donc mon
idole quand j'avais 16 ans et puis je
joue donc l'école des femmes à 16 ans il
ya une mini tournée et je joue à
brétigny sur orge en banlieue parisienne
et je suis donc avec des gens qui sont
beaucoup plus âgée que moi et qui vont à
l'époque dîner et décide d'aller dîner
chez ali rue des lombards qui était le
resto de nuit de l'époque où vous se
retrouvait tout le showbiz mais bon moi
je le savais pas j'avais 16 ans c'est un
espèce de truc qui ressemblait à rien
j'étais vraiment j'étais pas fini
j'étais une personne pas finie quoi 16
ans et mes amis étaient arrivés avant -
dans le resto et y'avait juin et donc
moi je descends les marches comme ça et
je voyage l'un qui on me voyant elle
avait donc été prévenus par mes amis ils
se lèvent vient vers moi et me prend
dans les bras et me dit c'est vrai que
tu m'aimes et moi admis heiva nui
cheville c'est pas que je vous aime
ce qui je vous adore j'ai fait comme ça
et en fait il était bien il était bien
peut-être il avait un peu picolé de ça
et il m'a dit tu veux être actrice tu
seras une star ce qui est hyper sympa de
sa part
sauf que moi je les crues et que comme
c'est la première personne qui m'a dit
tu seras une star tout ça mais il
tombait bien parce que j'avais 16 ans
c'est ce que j'avais besoin d'entendre
je suis rentré chez moi je n'ai pas été
au lycée pendant trois ou quatre jours
je je planais giteau plaph tard on
revient avec vous marina foïs et on
avait quelque chose d'autre à vous
montrer l'émission était jeune alexis
super et quant à 10 h à bord vous êtes
con monsieur c'était génial
vous êtes en train de faire le post
générique à on tourne le pré générique
avant l'émission près généré que vous
devez me dire ah j'ai peur j'ai promis
de la faire
ah d'accord c'est parce qu'on est
nouveau à l'atelier tooway c'est
compliqué parce que nous on vient du
théâtre tu vois le théâtre cédé 3 coûte
un coût pour le public à coup pour le
roi pour la reine est à une seconde
ouais c'était une période bénie
franchement et puis voilà farruggia il a
changé notre vie et surtout ça s'est
fait de manière tellement élégant de sa
part comme si de rien n'était est venu
nous voir à fontainebleau gens dans une
étable en eti dans la boue on jouait une
pièce qui était sûrement plein de charme
est bon il nous a produit au théâtre à
paris nous a fait faire de la télé il
nous a créé des vocations qu'on ignorait
nous mêmes il ay la plus compris que
nous qui nous étions ça c'est hyper fort
alors justement il nous a dit deux ou
trois choses qu'ils pensent de vous elle
a un talent immense et en plus elle a ce
talent immense de savoir choisir ses
rôles qu'ils soient dans le cinéma
d'auteur qui soit dans la comédie
populaire qui soit au au théâtre
subventionné enfin les extraordinaires
marie bat on s'aime dominique et moi
[Musique]
vous n'aimez pas claquer la bise à tout
le monde dès la mi mai mais surtout vous
n'aimez pas le lait vous adorez tout ce
qui vient du japon et plus
particulièrement les aubergines aux miss
au petit vous vouliez travailler dans un
péage et sinon vous êtes super forte en
bricolage votre premier souvenir de
cinéma c'est le film la strada de
fellini votre premier véritable rôle
c'était dans la tour montparnasse
infernale d'eric et ramzy
vous excellez dans la comédie est votre
rêve à ce moment là c'est un rôle à la
sacha baron cohen dans borat
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'adore franchement c'est extraordinaire
je ne sais pas ce qu'ils me fait plus
rire je crois que ce qui me fait plus
qu'une prostituée numéro 4 c'est absurde
beaucoup de gens aura écrit c'est la
prostituée numéro un et ben non eu des
cris numéro 4 voilà d'ange latorre parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas de
limites et c'est beau quand il fait par
exemple dans borat la scène où il est
dans le cul d'un autre homme quoi
personne a le cul poilus d'une autre
personne ce qui me fait la scène me
ferme au cimetière c'est d'imaginer que
lui même il est réalisateur
donc il va dire coupé et il ya de fortes
chances pour qu'ils disent on a refait
de vie va se remettre du même nom ce
trou du cul ça sur voilà ça me c'est un
héros quelqu'un devait de pour moi c'est
une forme d'héroïsme
allez on change un peu de registre avec
votre tout premier rôle dramatique si
vous voulez qu'on avance on s'en va
faire tout dire
me sortir la vraie vérité
impossible à dire la vérité
si j'enlève la broderie est ce que la
merde et la main ça n'intéresse personne
ça fait pas une belle histoire des
histoires comme les miennes y en a
pleins beau terroir mais des gens ce
qu'ils veulent tous c'est des belles
histoires avec des gens ont beau la
merde des inconnus sans exploser
ce monologue lie me bouleverse parce que
dire en fait presque elle parle de -10
la mer d'ordinaire ça n'intéresse
personne sont la broderie
rien n'est intéressant et ça ça pourrait
être le résumé d'une vie d'acteur en
fait moi le cinéma c'est la broderie de
ma vie que leur réalité étant ce qu'elle
est moi j'ai la chance par rapport aux
autres de pouvoir m'échapper dans des
fictions elle parle de la nécessité de
la fiction qui m'anime qui anime
beaucoup de gens voilà moi j'ai
l'occasion de que ce soit mon métier
donc mon activité principale et elle
elle dit ça dans sa vie de misère
voilà et j'ai rencontré la vraie darling
et je l'aimais infiniment bon allez
maintenant on écoute un peu la radio
vous êtes beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux
moi oui valbuena est solide ça faisait
vrai ou pas oui par exemple assez bas
c'est à dire que je m'occupe plus de
monde instagram que de mes enfants je
pense sur votre mur on compte 295 1000
followers et 742 photo de vous oui mais
surtout des gens qui vous inspirent
david bowie huit fois
non
ouah
[Musique]
jack nicholson six fois isabelle huppert
cinq fois catherine deneuve dix fois et
puis huit photos de fessiers mais le
très grand vainqueur c'est gérard
depardieu avec 20 apparitions
bah oui gérard depardieu c'est l'amour
de ma vie et pour le coup j'ai bon goût
grc ainsi un génie il n'y a pas d'autres
employés
il est oui c'est un court métrage que
j'ai fait avec lui et ça vous a fait
quoi de jouer avec lui j'ai joué
plusieurs fois avec lui ça n'a pas
d'équivalent c'est à dire que c'est
cosmique
il a une telle présence une telle
incarna sur pied il ya deux trucs à
l'acteur qu'il est aujourd'hui mais
c'est aussi toute la mémoire du cinéma
moi je sais pas combien de films j'ai vu
avec lui quand on est face à lui moi
j'ai moi j'ai rien à faire je me pose à
ses côtés et il embarque et je décolle
franchement pour finir on va écouter une
dernière archives est ce qui vous arrive
de mentir oui surtout une interview mais
non bassi exemple parce qu'il manquerait
plus qu'il faille dire la vérité
marina foïs est-ce que vous avez menti
au cours de cette interview je rappelle
que vous êtes à l'affiché d'une intime
conviction d'antoine rimbaud en salles
actuellement merci marina foïs d'être
passé sur le plateau de tchitchao
remercie
[Musique]